i think in my genre of the jewelry
business which is very interconnected
with hip-hop artists use jewelry to
express their individuality their
creativity instead of having a piece of
art hanging on the wall they prefer to
have it around their neck what's up gq
this is waffy from jewelry unlimited and
you're watching on the rocks
i started working in my dad's little
kiosk when i was 12. our average ticket
item was 50 so it was really from the
bottom up in 2008 i started my own
company and today is where we are
we have always operated as a family run
business where customers feel like
family i
enjoy selling jewelry face to face i
enjoy having relationships with clients
waffy responsible for at least about
four or five hundred thousand dollars
worth of the jury that i got shout out
to wifey jury unlimited i got this from
waffy these two was made by why are you
watching this you owe me a percentage
don't forget don't think i forgot this
qc piece was made for little baby p
who's the owner of qc wanted to do
something special for him last year it
has the qc logo but it also say can't be
with p liked it so much he's like make
me one too he's all emerald cuts in the
back invisible set the qc is raised with
like big stones pointers on the top the
cuban was also made to match this where
it alternates emeralds and round cut
diamonds it caused pee close to two
hundred thousand a piece sourcing of
diamonds it comes down to purchasing
power if there's a jeweler that doesn't
make that many pieces
they would buy diamonds just for that
particular piece if there's one who
is capable of purchasing larger
quantities than holding in stock get a
little bit better pricing and then there
are jewelers that are buying straight
from lines and cutting out the entire
wholesale market they get the best
prices and they buy the largest
quantities and i'm proud to say that i'm
dealing directly with the minds so this
is drummer gang logo this was made for
rapper out of la his name's greedo he's
currently incarcerated this whole
conversation and this vision was
communicated directly
by a phone while he's in a jail cell he
wanted to make this we did we wired us
the money and here it is and it's just
waiting for him to get out and be able
to enjoy it it's his logo
it's got
multicolored diamonds with this infinity
link with emeralds in the little
pockets wherever we could set them all
handset very heavy so something like
this would take 25 to 30 different parts
so this hand is one piece this glove is
a piece the drumstick is a different
piece because uh you can't make this out
of a single casting two hundred thousand
it's heavy i need to put it down this
one actually young thug placed the order
to make it for his friend i showed it to
him and he loved it so much he ended up
buying a different gift for his friend
and saying you know what just customize
it for me so we further customized it
where we added a second s on top i think
we are malleable in the way that we can
cater to the clients so if there was
something new that a client would bring
to me i would be very capable of
presenting it to them and executing the
idea might sound crazy from the
beginning but
i mean we've put full-on circuit boards
in
pieces of jewelry where like a fully
functional traffic light or a fully
functional rubik's cube everything is
crazy until it's not
this is another piece for little baby
again cbfw can't be with this one he
wanted to incorporate large stones and
this is pretty much the largest point as
you can put on a pennant like this these
are 70 pointers meaning each stone is
0.70 carat and sourcing these 43 i think
43 big stones in the air matching
quality it's a task so this is polo g's
1300 and then it has these street signs
that i uh intersect on the bale he
wanted the burgundy diamonds on top
three-dimensional this is a big piece
it's almost six inches so this polo g
this was i think when his first album
came out he wanted his album cover in
the face of the watch which was i've
never seen that before and this is a
paddock philly which was a lot less
money back then but now it's a lot more
but this is also apologies this is his
label oda only dreamers achieve this is
done in emerald cuts along with round
cuts around it which round is just your
basic round brailling cut these are the
other cut which is baguettes baguettes
tend to be skinnier longer stones
emerald cuts are shorter wider but they
take up less surface area and therefore
not only does it cost more per carrot
but it also you end up using more
carrots to make jewelry this is a piece
for somebody from the fpg camp fpg's
futures label we made him one and now
i've made like maybe two dozen of these
in different sizes that are for his crew
i made one like this for estg however
this is for one of his partners the
partner wanted it to be able to spin
yeah this one is about 60 000 maybe like
80 carats of diamonds this one was made
for qc artist bankroll freddy he's from
arkansas and he loves his state and
here's another one both of them for
bankroll freddie this particular one was
sixty thousand again used incorporating
emeralds everything is casted in its
entirety and the diamonds are all
handset bbs so
it gets expensive this one was 35 000.
these two were made for jarvante davis
this is his company gtd and this was a
piece he had me make earlier i'm not
sure why
this the pendant alone was 45 000. this
one the pendant alone was 25 000. so the
wolf pack piece was i made about three
years ago it's for the owner of wolf
pack global which is the label that
signed little baby it was also all
virgins had heavy heavy piece with these
gold accents about 75 000 for the
pendant the cuban was not included but
that was about 50 more so this this
pendant i made for one of our good
friends he's a local entrepreneur uh his
name is vic pennant includes larger
pointers on the bezel emerald cuts in
the back that's his logo in the middle
held up by this beautiful baguette
tennis chain that graduates from a
smaller to larger size and the larger
size really gets large it's about 12
millimeters in the middle very expensive
stones when you get into those sizes
yeah it's one of the prettiest pieces
watches is actually the reason i got in
the business i have a special affinity
liking towards watches these are a few
of the brands we carry rolex richard
mill audemars piguet paddock philly or
dominant brands today patek philippe is
my favorite brand i mean i've wanted one
since i was making 550 an hour and i i
was able to buy one
in um in 2008 which was probably the
best purchase i've ever made it was a 25
000 watch which is now worth 250 000
something very interesting is going on
in the watch market which is our economy
is seeing hyperinflation so
the inflation on luxury products or
through the roof for example this watch
right here pre-pandemic 120 000. today
300 000 is a great deal there's not many
investments one can make that they can
enjoy wear own
while making money and it goes across
the board even diamond pieces like these
this watch itself this is a patek
philippe 5726 which is a moon phase
larger case size
this used to be selling for
approximately ninety thousand today two
hundred thousand it's a good deal supply
again is so limited but anybody who
comes in to sell me a watch is not
leaving with that watch because i'm
buying it i attend these watch uh shows
i have my reputed dealers that i've been
working for years but sourcing them is
always sourcing them for the right price
is the is the challenge i mean
technically as a jeweler i need to
purchase the watch plane and then add
the diamonds to it now there's only a
few models i can say
that today cost less than
plane
and here's an example like this model
right here is the patek philippe 5980
this watch is probably the only watch
that would sell a little bit less than
the plane version would because of the
lack of production of this watch because
they're so hard to find and the demand
has skyrocketed same with these
skeletons the watch actually today the
plane watch has outperformed the iced
out watch i enjoy dressing it up when i
say dressing it up i mean icing it out
that in itself is an art because you get
to manipulate the diamond setting and do
things that have not been done before
these two are the exact same watch but
this one has been iced out with
significantly larger stones there's
about 60 different sizes of stones that
go into creating one of these this is
our big stone setting this is literally
exclusive just to us this is something
that is honeycomb flower set one of the
best settings available in the market
but this is just something with that
extra pizzazz where you were able to
manipulate 20 more carats of diamonds
into the same surface area that's
something that we did last year that has
been very very popular and for good
reason these are just
our presidential so rolex makes many
different models presidential being one
of the best investment pieces there's
solid gold there's rose gold white gold
yellow gold and there's a platinum right
here this is your classic i think a lot
of people associate a rolex with a solid
gold rolex with this type of bracelet
which is the presidential bracelet i
mean this is the 40th anniversary
presidential which comes with a green
face that again has skyrocketed in value
today trading at like 95 to 100 000 when
beginning of the pandemic i remember
selling some for 28 20 32
and now there's a hundred and
that's triple people have understood
that and it has made more money than the
stock market recently this is a special
piece this is our rm1103 red quartz it
is one of the lightest timepieces for
its size the entire case is fabricated
out of red quartz i think the retail on
this might be around 200 000 but trading
it around half a million here's a
a little bit older model it's a 1101
this one the case is made in rose and
titanium now trading at about 300 000.
this one is uh 1102 that came out after
the 1101 before the 1103 probably around
275 and this is a limited mancini i
think he's a race car driver that they
made in collaboration with titanium
around 260 000. and this this is a small
small sample of the pieces we've made we
as a company like to push the envelope
and try new things the biggest pieces
and the craziest pieces that i have in
mind are the ones i'm working on today
thank you gq for stopping by my shop
hopefully we can do another episode in
my new shop that opens up this year